this concludes the future of privacy and
security track at the microsoft research
summit
thank you for taking the time to join us
today and we thank our speakers and
panelists for their valuable insights
we hope that you found the sessions
engaging and informative
at microsoft trust is a cornerstone of
our relationships with individuals
businesses and governments
our investments in new security and
privacy technologies are aimed at
enhancing trust in the systems and
services we all depend on
as we look to the future of ai of
elections technologies and of online
systems in general we've seen a variety
of emerging challenges that pose
interesting questions for the future of
research
how can we develop robust and reliable
artificially intelligent systems while
guaranteeing the privacy of the users
who provide the data that's critical to
their development
how can we build and deploy systems that
enhance the trust and confidence of
ordinary voters allowing them to verify
that their votes have been correctly
counted
and finally how can we guarantee the
security of online systems even as they
grow in scope and
complexity to address these questions we
are leading the way in the development
of new differentially private
technologies for data analysis and
machine learning ensuring that we
maximize the value of data for new ai
systems without compromising customer
privacy we're investing in new secure
computation and homomorphic encryption
technologies to provide end-to-end
guarantees on the confidentiality of
computations
we're committed to the development of
systems that can support the integrity
of our elections and we're continuing to
drive the state of the art in building
secure systems through secure parsing
technologies and related security
features
through these investments and many more
we'll continue to build the trust and
confidence that's central to our
business
with the help of research across
microsoft and in our collaborations with
academic researchers we believe we can
address these open problems and empower
every person and every organization on
the planet to achieve more